you
[Music]
I'm Mike Sinclair with hardware lab art
that Patrick directs yeah the guy the
guy with flash color here I know no HR
people here I'll get you next anyway he
and I go back a long time we grew up in
Phoenix Arizona and I sent around a CV
which takes a long scroll to read
through you probably read the highlights
on the on the talk announcement but he
got his graduate training on up at the
universe of Pennsylvania in biophysics
no Steve do biophysics oh that's it went
school with Candice Bergen at University
of Pennsylvania and was honored with a
tour on scholarship and he attended
Trinity College in Cambridge for a year
right down the hall with Prince Charles
yeah we got to talk to dinner with the
Queen he became professor of a number of
universities in and around Boston and
Philadelphia Shay Institute he was vice
chairman chairman and ophthalmologist
ophthalmology department and one thing
that I like to brag on him besides I'm
always Steve's brother when we were in
close in high school was that he gets
interested in and anything and
everything just like me everything shiny
around there and grabs our attention
even though he's an ophthalmologist of
the retina most of his patients are are
afflicted with diabetes and he got
interested in the endocrine system
learned all about it and was the
president of the American Diabetes
Association for two years
the Pennsylvania Chapter so that's how
he gets involved and he believed me he's
very passionate about what he does and
he as you find out gets very involved
and what is interested in and he's going
to talk to you about what he truly is
interested in so oh growing up
a couple of science fair Awards on
hypothermia include a suspended
animation he let me build his electronic
equipment I built a defibrillator for
bringing Rats back to life and a
diathermic machine and which was easy I
can I can describe it it's a handheld
microwave oven I built for bringing the
rats back to life when a desk lamp just
cooked them so anyway and we tested
their brain activities and then we were
both in the amateur rocketry Club we
would launch them and try to get them
into low-earth orbit but didn't come
close anyway Steve's in North North
Phoenix ok is so as Mike explained I'm
an ophthalmologist I don't know if you
know how to spell that but my
responsibility here is to entertain you
for the next hour or so I have two
purposes that I have to outline at the
beginning the first is I appreciate all
of the things that you're trying to do
in the assist world for VIPs visually
impaired people I want you to better
understand what their vision problems
are so that then you will be better
enabled to take care of them and a
system my second is that I am
impassioned by this but I would like to
be associated in your projects I'd like
to help however I can by phone or
whatever but I also want to get you
interested in some of my projects so
those are my two purposes here okay to
help you to better understand about the
visually impaired person and then
hopefully to develop some camaraderie
and forward motion
okay so whoops there we go first a
little bit of anatomy here okay so this
is my ball the two eyeballs are
positioned looking hopefully at the same
target in the distance by six muscles
that have to be drew derived by the
brain input that overlays those two
images and inside the eyeball just like
a camera you have a lens in the front
that is a bag of gel so that muscle
contracts and pulls that
Lancel that's what allows you to focus
in and out the limbs as you age becomes
more hardened that protein becomes more
hardened and fractured and that produces
the glare the haze of a cataract okay in
the back is most of you are young enough
that you probably don't know what film
is okay that film the retina notice how
it's the yellow line here that stretches
all the way around the inside of the eye
gives us our wide field of vision takes
the picture so to speak but then of
course it has to send the image through
the optic nerve to the brain and of
course you've got to have a little bit
of brain back there that overlays the
two images to allow you to see one image
and we'll talk about death perception
okay that's the normal eye the center of
that retina is the macula that's what
gives us our best focused vision in the
center okay here's the cataract and when
you develop a cataract the surgeon goes
in and sucks out the cloudy protein and
inserts a lens most often inside the
capsule that remains this lens is most
often the single focus lens so they try
to focus you out there to distance and
you have to wear reading glasses to
fine-tune that focus for up close
they're developing new lenses that if
you want to we'll talk about those there
are a lot of problems with those I've
testified in front of the FDA about the
vision problems that can develop with
those okay but in the back of the eye
that macula this is what we see when we
look back there here's the optic nerve
intact here are the blood vessels that
are on the inner surface of that retina
the light that is focused through has to
go all the way through the inner retina
to the rods and cones that are in the
outer layer so you have to vascular
supplies the inner retina that supplies
the nutrients for the inner two-thirds
of the retina this choroidal blood
vessel layer is unique in the human body
but both of these are unique and that
coral blood vessel has to not only
supply the nutrients for the rods and
cones but has to protect it against all
of that light energy that's focused
that retina so we're gonna talk about
that and what happens okay all right now
what you need to understand is for the
past 200 years or so the ophthalmologist
optometrists the eye care providers and
the optics industry have been focused
almost entirely on how do I better focus
the eye whether it's with contact lenses
glasses surgery or whatever is
predominantly on how do i improve that
optical transfer function of the eye
it's only really in the past five or 10
years that we have begun to understand
the macular disease that is now
throughout the world becoming the major
cause of mild moderate and severe vision
loss this is because of the huge wide
spread of diabetes 33 million in the
United States 30% of whom on the first
diagnosis of diabetes already have
retinopathy I already have retinopathy
and what we're learning is even that's
late in terms of its discovery but it
accelerates to about 83 percent of
diabetics on the average after 20 years
of their diabetes and it's exploding
around the world the second is macular
degeneration this is a failure of our
genes as we age it's a genetically
inherited problem with the inflammatory
and protecting of that pigment
epithelium between that coral blood
vessels and the outer nuclear rods and
cones that macular degeneration is now
15 million in the United States ten
times that throughout the world so in
China India in even in the Middle East
and in and although we think of it as a
northern European disease no it is
throughout the world okay one in three
people over the age of 20 over the age
of 70 are developing this problem okay
and the third is glaucoma which is less
but still a great significant impact in
vision all right I'm gonna briefly talk
about the et DRS chart which is the
derivative that has come to be from
these old Snellen chart because
everybody knows what the top letters are
on that Snellen chart right right
everybody knows okay so they developed
this chart for the early treatment
diabetic retinopathy study and it's not
only that there's five letters on every
single line but there's a standard
deviation in terms of three lines equal
halving of the visual angle 2082 2042
20/20 three lines 3 log Mars so this is
a log Mart chart that supposedly was
developed because well then we thought
that an equal amount of improvement
three lines of vision improvement was
going to be the same for everybody
whether you were going from 2080 to 2040
or 2040 to 20/20 we now realize that's
not the case but this is what everybody
uses ok again what I want to point out
is you're gonna hear predominantly about
these numbers of this severe vision loss
legal blindness or severe vision
impairment but that group is a small
percentage of the entire people that I'm
going to talk about that have really
severe visual impairment in terms of
their productivity their ability to
function their ability to work and all
of those that are almost 5 to 10 times
those numbers in terms of their visual
problems ok the problem with macular
disease is it's chronic it's insidious
it's progressive and the problem here is
we're discovering it far too late we're
discovering after everything has failed
and the vision has gone down and
although there's 3 to 6 billion dollars
a year spent in terms of the injections
that are given for Mac degeneration in
this our ability to recover vision is
piss-poor
very poor on average about one and a
half lines of vision improvement on the
chart four years of treatment with inter
ocular injections and only about a third
of them go any significant amount is a
three line improvement in vision okay so
what does this mean it means that
instead of the surgeons mentality I've
got to find the disease after it's
progressing don't worry I will take care
of you we have to develop the
oncologists
mentality which means screen screen
screen to pick up the onset and then
predict the progression of the disease
if we can do that we can manage these
these diseases so much better okay all
right
but we're failing this now and I want to
try to tell you why it's because first
of all the patients fail to comply what
do I mean by that I mean that let's say
in diabetics only about 15 to 35 percent
comply with the recommended annual
examination why is that
well that's because whenever I go to the
doctor he has to dilate my pupils and I
lose a whole day's worth or afternoons
worth of function in the office so a lot
of them don't want to go to see the eye
doctor until they perceive that there's
visual impairment the problem here again
is you're walking around with two eyes
that the brain merges together so you
often don't perceive a difficulty with
your day-to-day functioning until the
vision is severe often in the second eye
so they don't go until basing your
problem and they think it's their
glasses okay the screening by the
physician examination is really inferior
why because they're looking with white
light at the retina so only vascular and
hemorrhagic lesions can they see it all
will and even that's poor they can't
define changes that are occurring over
time or they say well but Steve I get a
baseline photograph and I look at the
patient and I go back and look at the
patient and I look at the photograph and
I can see the depth no I say no you
can't
oh you can't all right now we've had
improved retinal imaging over the last
10 years or so we've developed white
light cameras that can photograph
through an undiluted pupil but they only
use white light and so they have the
same limitations as that doctor they can
only see certain lesions
when they do the the pigment Airy
changes we have let's see here there we
go back up there we go so this is what
you can typically see here in a patient
with macular degeneration you see the
optic nerve on the left and you see the
atrophic dry areas where the vessels
have diminished periphery yep because we
get over that in conference position
giving you the dilation that lasts for 3
4 5 hours so they're trying more and
more more to do this ok all right
if we have developed scanning laser
coherence tomography they provide an
enhanced structural analysis like this
so you see this line going through this
section of the white light and here you
see the structural analysis of that
retina there but the problem here is
that the cost is prohibitive often
because these better imaging techniques
come in cameras that are run at 30,000
to 6070 thousand dollars so
predominately they're only available in
referred physicians but the other big
problem is similar in the radiologic
industry all of the images are
interpreted by a physician well you say
well he should know what hell he's
looking at but the problem is the
physician cannot define changes
occurring over time ok and what's more
we fail to understand the relationship
between those those changes structurally
and the vision changes in that eye
why is that oh and third is we fail to
attach digital measurements to those
interpreted fundus findings and as you
know medicine is going toward a process
of where we're trying to develop digital
methods of well following a disease
process over time so we can better
determine in the individual patient the
chronologic progression of those multi
variables that define that disease
process so hopefully we can predict the
disease and prevent it but we can't do
that with imaging
because we cannot now attach
quantitative measurements to that okay
one of the biggest reasons however is
because of the way we measure vision how
does every doctor in the world measure
your vision with the eye chart okay
we've used the eye chart for a hundred
and eighty five almost 190 years oldest
thing in medicine to use today older
than the stethoscope it has never been
validated terrible measure of vision
what does it measure come on gang what
does it measure it measures the central
black against white contrast edge
detection in the central one degree of
vision and under one light condition
whatever is the lighting condition in
that room or of that chart so it doesn't
measure the world of our colored
contrasts it doesn't measure the
adaptation it doesn't measure low
illumination bright glare illumination
it doesn't measure our ability to see
that but more so the person who has
macular degeneration is moving his eye
around so we can try to get the best
clear area over the chart so often you
will say age so those responses those
perception times are nowhere near what
is required for reading driving facial
interactions all those things that are
daily in our tech vision tasks which
part of our daily lives okay it's more
dependent upon the examiner than the
examinee and believe me every doctor
knows which tech to send in after the
procedure that says oh look at the
improvement that we got in your vision
with this surgery that idea and it's
limited by embarrassment okay how far am
I gonna drive you down the chart where
you say doc come on what are you trying
to do here yeah how many doctors start
from the bottom and ask you to read up
so it's not a true psychophysical
threshold
poorly correlated with activities of
daily living has never been validated
doesn't measure that what I call the
Swiss cheese of central vision and it
doesn't measure distortions in your
vision which when you move your eyes
they create moving distortions which say
when trying to read it's like trying to
follow the bouncing ball very hard okay
all right so what I say is the physician
fails to understand our real vision
problems the disability and he doesn't
understand that there's no loss caused
by macular disease which is different
from those previously caused by visual
focus or other problems because we fail
to measure functional vision now oh I'm
sorry just very quickly I'm gonna insert
in here because I think it's also
important for you to understand the
physician really doesn't understand the
ocular surface problems then primarily
I'm talking about here dry eye syndrome
what is dry eye syndrome well as we get
older I'm sorry I can't use that word as
we become more gifted chronologically we
become okay you produce less tears but
on top of that we're all running around
with this inflammation on the backside
of the eyelids that screws up the oils
that are normally produced onto the
tears help spread out break down the
surface tension and allow this tears to
spread out evenly over your cornea it
produces a lot of inflammation that
blocks those tear glands and what we're
now realizing is that with the focused
attention that these people have because
they have difficulties with their vision
so they're focused at what they're
looking at but all of you do focus on a
monitor all day long and what I say is
that God in her infinite wisdom didn't
design us to do this okay because what
happens is when you're focused at what
you're doing your eyes are not only not
moving much but you're not blinking your
blinking rates go down to about a
quarter of normal so this is what
produces that tearing that burning that
irritation that tired eyes okay
now just very quickly what do we measure
we're measuring ridiculous quantities
we're measuring yes the tear volume by
putting a little strip there we're
measuring osmolarity we're taking
infrared measure pictures of the
meibomian glands to look for occlusion
but we don't really measure what is
important so I'm trying to develop
working on a device remin hyperspectral
camera that will focus and look at the
tear film and it's and it changes in its
constituents and the inflammatory
reactions and is this viral is this
allergic is it bacterial or fungal and
what are the constituents in that tear
film but we're also I'm working with
Kristian Holt's to develop a blink
monitor that will blink how often you
are blinking during different tasks and
we've got to somehow stimulate you so do
we puff it with a little bit of air or
do we tweak it or do we say okay Mike
come on now let's blink blink blink
blink so we need something to really
help us because just trying to talk
about this doesn't remind you to do it
know if you're using artificial tears we
usually recommend it to use of a thicker
one they produce most of them are just
like water you put them on the eye and
they're gone in five seconds make a
little bit thicker there now trying to
produce artificial tears that have some
of the oils they're missing to put those
put it on it don't it doesn't it doesn't
okay all right all right now okay so we
have this improved retinal imaging
through and dilated pupils but devices
that are available now that are lowering
the cost is we have a scanning laser LED
multi-wavelength types of imaging that
are bringing down the price
significantly the iPhone lens I say no
no no no this is taking it's got a
little lens did you stick on the iPhone
and you can take a picture of your
retina but what are you gonna do about
it you're gonna mail it email it to your
doc it's it has a lot of problems okay
but what what we've developed and I'm
happy to share
some of that with you is a cloud-based
vendor-neutral so we can take export the
images from all the different fundus
capsules else Oct cameras all of these
and we export them to the cloud where
they're all registered and overlaid so
we can now allow the physician to see
changes between all the different
instruments and changes occurring over
time
smart medical image processing system so
here it is where you can see overlying
this you can see the fundus
autofluorescence picture and you can
overlay it with the oct images okay all
right so if we can use overlay of
registered images I can see changes now
occurring over time most the time this
is what you see
so here it's two pictures of an eye with
macular degeneration taken about six
months apart I defy you can you see
differences there come on come on you
see differences one's more blurry well
once a little bit lighter darker than
the other that's just because it all
right here okay all right but doc say I
can see the difference because this is
the way most often even with a single
camera the images are presented it
doesn't help the physician to interpret
what's going on and People magazine
point this out to me every week they
take one photograph altered a little bit
and you got to go back and forth back
forth back forth back forward to try to
find differences you can't see that but
if we overlay them you can see
differences immediately in terms of
changes now which changes are indicative
of progression of that atrophy that's
what we have to define and which are
associated with the vision problems
that's what we have to define but we can
look at angiograms we can look at
autofluorescence images we can look at
those Oct s and look at overtime so
here's the right left eyes of a fellow
with atrophic macular degeneration taken
here and a year later see look at how
these geographic areas have spread to
create more areas of smudgy
in their vision but how do we define
what are the structural important
aspects that we can predict that
progression in this fellow that I that I
that I that I that's what we've got to
go okay and we not only have to be able
to be able to detect those that are
associated with the vision problems but
detect them and analyze them so we can
get some quantitative information that
will help us to define where that person
is going so I've developed a program
called IQ draw
I'm sorry currently we use only
population based statistics on regular
hemorrhagic currently it's not very good
but AI programs are now being that
they've been two of them have been
approved by the FDA so we're we're going
there but right now they're not good
okay so we need digital quantification
and I do that by allowing the doctor to
draw on what he thinks are the important
lesions and then we can assign
quantitative numbers to that areas
parameters the the proximity to the to
the fovea so we can define how this
basically overlays with his vision and
look at them what are those changes are
predictive over time so this is a
physician derived way that we can now
use crowdsourcing to say well how did
all of these physicians look at these
images and define much better ways of
tracking those over time okay all right
it's now being evaluated so hopefully it
will soon be up on the Apple Store and I
think there's all kinds of additional
applications which I'm exploring talking
about neuroradiology dental photography
and and dermatological uation
okay all right now let's look real
quickly at vision assessment where are
we currently well besides the chart that
the doctor uses in your office we have
phones now that will present the Snellen
chart or the et DRS chart and maybe do a
little bit but they do not measure
functional vision at the those
functional fixation times
but I talked about okay 150 to 200 300
millisecond of things okay all right and
we do do visual field testing but
actually this is a derivative of an old
glaucoma method that just measures your
ability to see spots of light that are
contrasted against a white interface not
a visual field we call it that but it's
not an actual visual field okay it's now
being done in a much more expensive
camera well at least there they can hold
the fundus image and look to see how the
visual alterations at least defined by
the Humphrey Field spot detection
over lying on top of the macular
pathology so it's beginning to help us
to understand that but still not true
vision testing we can measure
distortions this is a 4c by a net
Lowenstein from anyway which which
basically looks at deviations in a line
and and you have to point it out it's a
crude measurement that's mainly used to
detect early neovascular Mac
degeneration it's not good enough actor
enough or inclusive enough to help us
assist the person in defining a way that
we can help him with those distortions
in their vision bailing glares bad and
yes how do we assess it now while we
hold up a little lighted hemisphere in
front of your eye that you look at the
chart through it and you see how much it
drops your lines of vision but it's used
purely to define for the government
whether you can do your cataract or not
they got the cataract and it doesn't
really provide measurements that are
important in understanding what the
person's disability is with regard to
glare problems okay all right I'm going
to talk to you briefly about a couple of
devices that I've developed the first is
the central vision analyzer central
vision screening and the Omni field
which is that the it's a resolution
visual field okay central vision
analyzer patient sits in the chair looks
at a mirror at a monitor that presents
landal sees round sees that are flipped
up down right or left as they're
presented patient responds with a
joystick reason now instead of the
button pad
and so the presentations are at the
standard 250 to 300 milliseconds and we
can go up or down in log Mar actually in
between the steps on the log mark chart
it's a true cycle physical threshold
threshing threshold in from the bottom
as well as the top and we can go up to
six different environments to simulate
real tasks that you have to participate
in during the day it is vision under
stressful conditions we recognize that
correlates with the activity of daily
living and adapts to patient response it
takes about two minutes to do okay so
here's a picture of some of the results
so you see this person with some macular
very mild Mac degeneration oh he has 20
13.6 he has better than 20/20 vision
under high contrast white letters
against the black but put him in a
romantic restaurant all right and his
vision goes down to legal blindness and
even worse if he's trying to drive at
night in that dim atmosphere should this
guy be driving at night no but there's
no legal prohibition but you see what
this is testing telling us about that
visual function here are some glare
modules so what we're trying to do here
is to measure your photopic vision under
standard lighting conditions in the Sun
okay and oh I'm sorry what you see here
is under high contrast is not quite as
good as the dark screen with bright
height Michelson 99% contrast because
you have the glare of the screen and but
look again what this showed us for the
first time is patients with macular
disease fail to respond to very bright
environments as well as those very dim
environments so you can see the
progressive loss so we use bandpass
filters pictures that have been
validated in order to show really what
so I can show this to the family and say
look Uncle Mike shouldn't be driving
look at what's happening one of these
conditions okay okay okay
FDA approved and it's been validated
against the nei of the FQ 25 all right
so I want to show you just some examples
here of what this is showing you so
these are several different kinds of
pathologies wet macular degeneration
epiretinal membrane dry macular
degeneration cataracts HIV disease these
were all done by dr. gomez down at UCSD
so you see here in a normal person yeah
they got 20/20 here at on the ETS chart
but under the high presentations dropped
a little bit but even under this log
marred the restaurant dining and night
driving drops down to 2040 for the
normal person but look at the severe
loss especially the wet Mac degeneration
which if we take the ETS chart they're
not bad but you look at this Mays Opik
kind of tasks that they have to do
severe function almost about legal
blindness on the average in these
patients so the ETRS chart is not a
reasonable measure of these people
function okay here's another one okay
and the photopic Glitter modules that we
just talked about again et viras chart
pretty good here from 2020 to 2030 - but
even the normal person under sunlight
okay drops down and look at the how
those others drop down much more
severely 2080 21 so there's still is not
quite as severe as under dim light but
still a significant those photopic
vision tasks that you have to
participate in okay all right so the
second thing I'm gonna have to move fast
I have positive dragon behind here okay
so this is the Omni field it's the
first-ever resolution visual field so we
present land alt C's but we presented at
25 intercepts in the central 20 degrees
why the central 20 degrees this is your
interactive visual field out here it
Orient's us in space but this is your
interaction okay and all the same thing
we do 20 of 250 milli second
presentation law
Maur steps central fixation control
using this toby eye tracker here and we
do these visual measurements so let's
look at at this okay so here's a fellow
with just Drew's drusen is the German
word meaning little rocks you probably
thought your husband's had rocks in
their heads but now you got rocks in the
back of the eyes but look at this okay
so the visual acuity here was 2025 but
what we see here is that that high
acuity here was not in the fixation but
off about 2 or 3 degrees so you see a
color coded here as we go down a
progressive maze Opik levels of how that
vision deteriorates and this is
difference from age match normals okay
but what you really want to know is how
does this guy compared to the normal
Hill of vision we use the hill of vision
you've probably heard that term which
means you've got 20/20 in the middle but
your vision in all of us drops down to
about 20 120 120 at 10 degrees X and
Christine okay hold up your hands and
show me what is 10 degrees eccentricity
from your central vision here here here
here here
you're too wide it's about right there
this no plus or minus 10 degrees 20 20
degrees twenty ten degrees eccentricity
20 degrees visual field this is your
interaction out here you're legally
blind all you can see is counting
fingers so what does this mean it means
that for normal people the cone of
vision decline from 2025
2040 or better is only about six seven
degrees in the center that you have sort
of reading capability in order to see
what's going on for young people
you all are better than us older farts
okay all right but which is restricted
even with normal people normal lenses in
the age group that that he'll a vision
drops down but you want to know in the
person with macular
zees what is their hill of vision where
do they have the areas that they can see
2040 or better so they can read and do
things of that sort
okay not just what is their chart acuity
okay
all right therefore beyond 46 degrees
there so you see pictures of couples
when they're looking at each other and
they're madly in love and they're
looking at each other and their eyes are
going all around why because your facial
features are low contrast and you've got
to see them with a pretty good
resolution so you can't just look at the
eyes in the center you've got to look
all around yes that's that's an that is
an IRS definition of legal blindness
when you have in the center 20200 that
is legally blind that means you cannot
see well enough to hold down a job drive
even probably take public transportation
things of that sort
okay that's a legal definition all right
okay
onward okay so here's a person treated
with Avastin for macular degeneration
wet you can see the leaky blood vessels
here under the center of the vision and
you can see his vision Harry now he
measures 2060 on the chart where in
God's name is he seen 26 well he may be
seeing it somewhere sort of right out
here at about 6 degrees eccentricities
so he's moving his eye around and he can
find that that area but look at how
severe that vision is below normal
because of that small little wet Mac
degeneration center here he's treated
with Avastin and still 2060 on the chart
here the the neovascularization is
shriveled down and the center is still
bad but he's starting to get more vision
around the sides and again here 2060
again but he says doc my vision is much
better because he's using a lot more of
his Perry axial vision to function we're
finding that people can
at kanri function but we've got to
better know how to assist them in some
sort of rehabilitation therapy and in
the assist devices as well so that we
can make use of these areas of the
visual field okay all right okay now
here's another one so you say well how
do I know that this is anything real
under there okay so here's a engineer
who basically had a little vascular
occlusion right up here and now this is
flipped remember the patient's facing me
so that's one way and remember lenses
turn things upside down so here's this
visual field but what it sure has showed
us here is that the vision scotoma is
much larger than I would have thought
from that little area of the vascular
occlusion and leakage but this engineer
oh so the Omni field generated this
picture and this guy in Photoshop drew
this very similar the only thing that I
didn't have here are the distortions
caused by the swelling in that area of
his vision okay and so I started asking
well down here I made it much more
recent no Steve you really right it's it
is more blurry down here and so we went
back and forth back and forth and looked
at the different sectors so these are
realistic interpretations of what the
patient is seeing from this okay here's
another woman who is the artist and and
again in the Omni field generated this
picture based on this vascular occlusion
which is not only ischemic here but has
these little extensions jook jook that
went up around the fovea right there
so that's Jill choked down here in terms
of the vision loss and so this is what
the omni field generated and this is
what she generated and I said Jeannie
all right yeah up here where the
ischemic retina is that's pretty bad
everything but I said but you didn't you
didn't smudge these here and she said oh
Steve no no you're right I was wrong I
should have done this much more smudged
over here and we talked about the
position of this scotoma is where she
drove
did it mostly she says no I was moving
my hat around a little bit more so what
I'm trying to say is it's quite
realistic in terms of the interpretation
of this is what the patient is sees okay
real quick now
so devices in development where we want
to go with this Omni field is right now
we're limited by the hardware that we're
now using central 20 degree diameter
2020 we need to in order to measure the
fine fixations of the very good
especially my pilots that come in and
I'm measuring them but the fixation is
monitored by the tobe pupil eye tracker
and we're having difficulties with this
in patients who wear glasses because of
the glare reflected our measurement of
pupil fraction is not that good so where
do we want to go we want to go to an
some sort of a head mounted display
device that will do this for us so I
need to be able to to basically do it we
tried it with off-the-shelf of AMR and
although we could put in the lenses and
try to put an eye tracker and everything
in it wound up to be okay we could do it
you know in our in our in our in our lab
but trying to get a production model was
impossible so the vive pro lie has 2880
16 over but i don't know what the
they're not out in production yet so i
haven't been able to find out oh that
2880 what does that spread over in terms
of the field of view and they do use a
toby height record that's up up close in
the head-mounted display but i don't
know much about this device but i'm here
to talk to you all about the hololens
project to see if there's possibility we
can do this or possibly with the you
know your devices but i got to be able
to track fixation I fix a shim so I can
hold fixation still or if they're moving
their eyes I can move the presentation
to the right intercepts in the visual
field and know where I'm measuring them
I'm sorry what kind of speed I gotta go
back and look that up I don't know okay
I'll be honest I don't know okay now but
the thing that I want to relate to you
is
doing these visual fields has allowed me
to much better see through the eyes of
the patient I can better understand what
their visual disability is and I'm
hoping that we can buy better defining
these by assessing the the the patient
will be better able to develop assist
devices and and and occupational I'm
sorry that's I hate that word let's just
say it there are puny methods of
rehabilitating them okay all right and
what this shows is that near vision
tasks as well as distance vision tasks
are very commonly our vision is our most
precious asset we want to be able to
have this to function we want to be able
to work with it but on the whole we're
not using assist devices to do that and
my sense and talking with the patients
that are frustrated because their kids
will go out and buy them a lens or the
Bible whatever and they can't use it so
where are we now
oh I'm sorry I'm trying I'm working
toward developing and tablet based let's
call it vision testing app okay and the
first it will include a what's called a
visual function questionnaire and this
is like a quality-of-life questionnaire
but it's much more structured because
the problem with quality of life
questionnaires like the orthopedics how
much pain do you have one to ten well
everybody's going to give you a
different number but these are more
structured this was the first one that
was the IVF queue that was compared
against the any IVF queue but we've
developed a much better one more
recently so we're testing both and it's
it's gender oriented so near vision
under bright light near vision under dim
light tasks and distance vision under
dim light and bright light tasks but
we've also tried to structure the
ability so we can compare patients and
we can compare over time much better so
this is the vfq the first of four
aspects to this tablet-based
function testing for both the office as
well as home use the second is to put
the central vision analyzer on a tablet
so I can use sweeps
as the Caesar presented but since the
central vision analyzer doesn't have to
track vision I don't have to worry about
it but I got to be able to tell how far
the tablet is away from the face in
order to make this successful okay I
would like to include the Omni field and
a new method that Mike and I have been
talking about to measure distortions in
the vision so we can try to figure out
ways to to to work with them prove it
now and once they prevent them to to
counter them so they're not so
disturbing when people are trying to
read and and look at things but we need
we need vision tracking in order really
measure those okay so that's waiting I'm
hoping to discuss more about those
projects and how that might be
incorporated into some sort of tablet
based design hopefully in an app that we
can put on the market there for general
not only office use but home use okay
now well I've gone much much too long so
let's really talk real quickly about
assist devices okay the first chart are
magnifying lenses and these over all
have a lot of problems the limited field
of view the failure to understand the
Swiss cheese of the vision I just think
around if I magnify it I'll be able to
see it poor positioning and tremors but
the major problem is the failure to
understand the light through these
things because most people will read it
no they may have a light in the
magnifier but those are usually LED
lights that are Clary and piss poor now
a lot of people will read how many of
you read with the light over your right
shoulder your mother told you to read
with the light over your right shoulder
right okay when you do that it puts your
print in shadow I've got to tell these
patients read with the light coming in
low and from the side or read in the
morning with the light coming through
the window to the side okay but even
with the best of these magnifiers
reading are 15 to 18 words per minute
one
every four come on
it's just unsatisfactory okay they're
now producing some distance magnifiers
that are over-the-counter focusable
using two lenses they were primarily
used for sports but are used a lot by my
patients watching TV and they make some
new middle-distance ones so that you
don't have to get up real close to
magnify to the monitor you can sit back
and use these over-the-counter
magnifiers okay
they have distance glasses that are more
patient prescribed or high just hike on
high magnifiers that surgeons used in
surgery and they're used by a lot of my
patients walking around driving because
you can where I live use them the
problem with surgery is you've got
coaxial lighting with your lenses what
I'm going to show you is that destroys
death perception talk about that okay
alright so oh how about over-the-counter
glasses for glare okay well most of you
I don't see any glare I don't see any
you know sunglasses here you you you you
picked the ones based on frames right
right okay
okay now what we have to realize is that
in our lighting circumstances going from
dim light where we really have to
function to very bright sunlight that's
about a 12 long unit change only about
10 percent of that is due to the pupil
the other has to be adaptation of your
retina to those huge light levels that
takes time
but your retina has to adapt and in each
light level you've got to have a certain
contrast light differential to allow you
to see those targets though those
targets have to be proportional to the
background illumination and this is why
in dim light levels you can't see
because of the overall lighting levels
and the contour
are so minimal at those reduced levels
but also what we've now reported is that
very high saturation levels the retinas
in these macro generation patients is it
fails to say that there over saturate
their bleached okay all right so an
off-axis glare produces severe reduction
the loss effect on the targets that
we're trying to view okay all right so
here's your sunglasses and it's
according to price frame design
polarized all that marketing gizmo that
means nothing in terms of vision I try
to recommend to my patients go into a
store and take all the sunglasses
outside and try to find the one that did
that do it for you most often they're
not allowed to do that okay but if you
select the best type intent most often
for shopping in fluorescent lighting or
monitor glare they'll pick a pale yellow
what's typically called night driving
glasses because it reduces the hid head
like their that helps to relax the eyes
a lot but in some people that are prone
to migraines it can cause some problems
there so we have to again find the tint
that is right for you for some likely
the most often select a much paler amber
tint than I would have ever anticipated
not the dark Maui gems or whatever but
pale amber or amber purple seems to do
it the thing that I've realized that
there's variability on among all my
patients no one choose size fits all
we've got to develop a kiosk where you
go in and you select the the tints that
are going to do it for you and then you
get your glasses prescribed okay all
right all right so real quick assist
devices that are electronic their paper
video magnifiers that will take an image
of the paper and basically present it on
the screen and allow you to magnify it
or they'll use OCR but most of them are
not internet connected office or home
base use and they run 3,500 to 3,000
bucks
the portable ones yeah you can take
around but their field of view is much
more restricted much more difficult to
use there's one here that is the New
England low vision that you can take a
picture of here but you still have to
use it
with a monitor am I gonna take it around
with both so we haven't really fought
this out okay what I am realizing is
that the older more mature generation is
far is using tablets and laptops far
better far more than I ever anticipated
okay they're using them for reading
newspapers documents emails Facebook
banking bill paying FaceTime with their
kids and Friends book reading and gaming
but they're most the time they're
playing puzzle games kind of things on
it okay and a lot now are using it for
online shopping because they can't drive
and it's hard to get their family to
take them to the store and I'd like to
say well this is why Amazon bought whole
foods I don't know that for sure but
when I go to Whole Foods that those
those shipping carts are usually spat
with online shipping shopping for for
those local needs okay all right okay so
the problems though that I find again
for my patients complaining a lot is
these laptops these tablets don't allow
you to really adjust those aspects of
the presentations okay the mouse pointer
is difficult to follow
okay touchscreen finger spreading allows
you to magnify the print yeah but it
doesn't allow you to adjust and you lose
your orientation and there's a lot of
problems with that doesn't allow you to
adjust personally the screen the
contrast the illumination the color
management especially when you're doing
Internet online shopping that's what
you'd like to do in order to really be
able to maybe some of the women who are
into the color management the you know
it's not part of the white chromosome
but still still we need to allow the
person to better personalize that
interaction to be able to function and
so although there is OCR most of them
tell them it's boring it doesn't
function we need to really improve
okay alright so and now other commercial
there's all kinds of online books that
my patients are reading more and more
and more more now because they're stuck
at home and so they go on to audible
mostly they're using nukes or Kindles
but when I'm trying to get the local
libraries that are now converting more
to downloadable for their constituents
they all use different readers and so
this has been a real problem here okay
these are all National Association for
the blind and National Foundation for
the blind produce readers but I find the
interactions come on gang the
interactions are difficult okay an app
that you all have been developing and I
think now is available isn't it Mike the
seeing AI if this is I think it's
fantastic in okay now I realize it's
primarily oriented toward the severely
vision impaired but its ability to
narrate the world around you to sort of
to help you to know what's going on and
to describe the people that you're
seeing and what they're doing and their
facial recognition I think this is great
because I just started reviewing these
things when Mike okay all right I think
it's remarkable but I want to tell you
what you need to go okay yeah I know
we're almost out of time so okay real
quickly
most of the head-mounted commercially
available devices help the person the
first was the Geordi autofocus then the
esight video cameras looking forward to
alt and you can log it alter the
contrast and the focus the see boost
which is which is it fit onto the
glasses so allows you to look through
one eye with the glasses and the other
but it's a purely an audible contrast
adjustment and illumination adjustment
that you can do with the handheld vision
there the or cam I think I like the best
it's got this little camera right here
on the edge of the glasses and it's
purely audible so it will read so you
point to a text
something that you want to read and
it'll read it for you I haven't had any
personal experience with it but I think
it has a lot of applications we're gonna
talk about in a second okay real quick
now some of the Microsoft VR programs
and stuff that you're working on again
primarily for the severe vision
impairment the cane controller the MS 3d
soundscape audio through the bone
conducting headphones that allow you
again to understand what's going on
around you through these virtual
transmitters I think it's great but it's
predominately for the severe vision
impairment I think we can we can do this
also for a thing I've been really
impressed with the mount Rogers project
that will enable not only the partially
sighted but been able to orient the
person in space with regard to what he's
looking at
we still have some problems I think in
talking about for for those with good
vision how much resolution we have but
hopefully that's going to be improved in
the near future as our screens improve
okay I think it's tremendous project and
using the non-dominant hand as well as
the dominant hand for different tasks
great ideas with this okay to allow the
person to really do it but they've got
to be able to see because most people
can't touch type the way at least I was
trying to do it so they got to be able
to see the tablet and to be able to
visualize those keys and maybe use the
club's method of discovering land as
they're typing okay and the prism
project will cost cameras to add to the
EMR goggles to add real-world video
based again I haven't had a chance to
really look at this very much but or to
to but I'd like to learn more about it
okay and the whole lens to I want to
know much more about it because of the
pupil tracking using the pupil labs
vision tracking inside of it I think
again is a is a tremendous potential for
doing this and for resolving the
external world as well as what you're
trying to view and or with
virtual reality kind of presenting the
the pictures are okay do we have to get
out of here so that you can present it
what's going on yeah no running over
2:45
oh you okay with that you guys okay all
right okay okay all right so so what
I've been talking to Mike is to is to
let's develop a much better tablet that
will assist the person much better in a
lot of the tasks that he wants to do he
gets a lot of paper I want to be able to
image that paper so we need it
positioned in a stand that will allow
imaging of the underlying paper but this
tack but I think the stand has to be
portable with the tablet one not like
this where the tablet is sitting on the
paper because it doesn't allow you to do
things underneath here that you would
like to do and be able to visualize it
magnified in the overlying screen too is
we need to provide the user interface
that enable the personalization that I
talked about okay Mike and I have talked
about a new way of presenting print
because what I told you is with the
magnifiers if we only have 15 18 words a
minute result in trying to read print
that's poor so the only resource in the
past has been to convert OCR and listen
Mike and I have been talking about RSVP
print rapid sequential visual
presentation so the whole idea here is
think about what happens when you're
trying to read you've got a look at the
left hand side of the print with both
eyes see as many letters you'll see
individual letters you just see word
forms then you got a saccade your your
view to the next group of words the next
group of words the next chord Allenwood
or tried to get us to expand that field
of view but we're often limited if
you're right field of view is limited
because of that macular degeneration as
you saw with those atrophic zones that
screws up the eyes don't know
one eye or the other I doesn't know how
far do I move to the right so typically
this ik adds remember your brain turns
off during that motion so when your
brain turns off your saw you come to
here and say oh I'm not in the right
place
oh I'm not in the right place so the
CICC adds the motions take up
three-quarters of the time not less than
one quarter of the time so if we could
define where your vision problem is we
ought to be able to go Bam Bam Bam here
in one place and allow you to see
without having to move your eyes okay we
need to control it so what I thought
about is we'll make a little verdict
vertical rib on the trackpad when you
move your hand over to the right that
speeds up the print did you do when you
move it to the left whoop sorry I'm I
press the left button when you move it
to the left it goes back because
typically we're reading we go backwards
and forwards and backwards and forwards
so this allows you to and we've been
able to it significantly increase the
reading speed in a number of these
patients by using this kind of text but
we're only just beginning this but we
need to understand also the natural word
progression so with longer words more
difficult words with punctuation with
all of this we've got to understand what
our normal hesitations in this rather
than just bang bang bang bang you say
wait a minute it's like you're on a
runaway train you know you got to be
able to control it okay
so here's this guy that I showed you
before he's got an area below here that
he sees so we can figure out how big
does the print have to be in there how
much spacing between the letters how
many letters can we present but what we
can do is bang bang bang bang like that
and present it to him in that area of
his vision he's got to be taught how to
use it but this is a derivation of the
visual fields that allow us to really
improve the reading in these patients
okay all right
and OCR can help in in some of the
patients they said it really helps
others say it's it just messes up their
comprehension so again this is something
that needs to be put in there okay all
right I'm going to just present real
quickly some projects for you to think
about shopping shopping okay
what do you do when you're shopping
you're going down these long aisles and
you've got to sort of say alright where
do I find the cereals for today okay
then you got to go and then there arm's
length tasks where you want to compare
products okay right well right now with
the AI site you have to basically you
can turn it around and read the barcodes
yeah but it's it's really cumbersome so
I think we need to somehow put into
glasses goggles some way of identifying
whether it's the or cam or some other
derivation how do we though know where
he's going to be looking do we have a
little laser printer or a laser pointer
that will point and turn the bottle
around or something so this I just want
you to think about this because this is
a real difficult project and people who
can't get their family to drive them
they gotta go they got a shop how do you
do prepared foods how do you assess
colors and textures and this in the
fresh foods okay so I think if we could
somehow get Whole Foods to not only put
the barcode or the price on the shelf
but if they could put a see a QR code
and tell about the constituents from the
bottles god it would help you a great
deal and not only the visually impaired
person but also the normal person is
just trying to look at oh which ones are
the gluten fries which ones are the I
think we're becoming more sensitive this
and we've got to enable it whether Whole
Foods will do this I doubt it but we got
to start thinking about this okay how do
you select meat okay how much does it
weigh is it going to be fresh well you
know when they show you meats in stores
it's under a blue white lighting
because it makes the meat look red and
fresh the fish is under white lighting
chicken is under white lighting okay but
again how do we assess this I think if
we can use haptics I'm talking to Mike
about possibly be using haptics and
other things to try to assess maybe with
a hyperspectral camera we can define
much better the rightness the freshness
the appropriate right now I talked with
the get of what the people from Hope
fool isn't when do you remove your
muffins and your breads from the shelf
ten days after they're put on the Shelf
don't have a fungus and whatever okay so
I think we need much better ways to
assess this especially if you're
shopping online how do you assess what's
gonna what you're gonna get from Whole
Foods vs. Giant versus Acme I think that
I'm sort of saying well maybe we need
some sort of independent company that'll
go in there and use their hyperspectral
camera and use their stuff and define
we'll get five chefs to walk in and oh
man these are really fresh and then you
we get the quantitative I don't know I'm
just throwing these out there because I
think this is a real problem okay
onward one of the problems that's really
social that I see from my parent
patients is recognizing faces down the
hall is there some way we can do it
we're gonna have to enhance the facial
contrast then textures okay because the
textures help you to see those facial
features much better just two approaches
right one approach is to enhance what
they're seeing judge for themself
yeah the other approach is just use an
automated system where the automated
system is identifying that Stephen
Sinclair and just telling him which I
think you ought to use the latter but I
heard that Google glasses ran into a
problem with some sort of aspect of this
cloud-based AI
with the inference on the part of the
people who were being imaged that yeah
and and so I want I would I prefer some
sort of combination so you can enhance
it so it's so that the camera can detect
the the facial features easier and the
emotional characteristics as well which
are different from the facial
recognition characteristics because you
got to see what that beautiful gal is is
thinking about what you're saying across
the table okay reading instructions for
appliances and all these things for
these people we've perhaps we can direct
them to a website with a QR code so they
can be able to go and read the
instructions much better than in that
paper form that they get with all of
their appliances and stuff we've got to
be able to enable them to to see this
okay the thing though that I think is
encumbering to a lot of your work is the
social acceptance of these goggles and I
know that you're expecting to improve
these dramatically but I think there's
also other ways we could go here the
both spectacle frames now are equipped
with audio so I think the esight the AI
and that stuff we could convert to that
hopefully with little cameras and stuff
with the audible and the orcam can we
hook this to the different ones and get
more VR virtual reality you know
presentation or or whatever I I think
but again we have to be careful about
the AI aspect but the or cam uses finger
pointing and so you can't go down the
hallway and say oh hi George uh so we've
got to find a better way of directing
and and doing this okay yeah I think so
if but how well can we do this I see
you've got to tell me this cuz I I'm not
aware yet how good it is on these pupil
labs or the tobe ones that are in your
glasses alright I want to get you
interested in kiddos just real quick
we'll finish up here we've got one
minute
okay we started this kid site program
because kids overall we don't discover
their vision problems until age 5-6 when
they go to school that's the first time
that we get any kind of formal testing
and it's usually done by a nurse in a
hallway with a Snellen chart and the kid
usually memorizes it or it's it's very
pretty
okay we need an interactive video game
that will measure their vision as they
play either with some sort of down the
hallway measurement of their you know
different things that I developed Fred
the Frog Freddy the Frog who would go
around the garden and these insects
would move around him and the the the
star order triangle the thing would
appear on his chest and then he had to
identify which of the insects had the
same thing so we would increase or
decrease the size of this one to measure
the central vision that we'd increase or
decrease the size of the images that
would appear on the side we try to do it
in a kid side this was about 20 years
ago because they got some funding
through Ronald McDonald House but it was
put on backburner
so I think we need both an app on a
tablet as well as down a hallway and
interaction so we can screen kids yes in
schools in a much more reliable way but
we can also have a tablet then they can
play with at age two one and a half or
two because kids now are using tablets
to play games very early age when we
have a chance to alter a lot of the
visual aspects during the growth and
brain learning so I'm saying
think about this think about this please
okay thanks very much the slide deck
that's on the drop box these are my
Sinclair technologies clear vision and
some clear retina and yeah okay
okay okay so it's - I'm one minute over
I apologize for keeping you so late I
hope it's been entertaining
I hope it's helped you to better
understand some of the things that I'm
thinking about
our failure as ophthalmologists
optometrists and whatever to really
measure what we're doing we're driven a
lot by the pharmaceutical industry when
it comes to macular disease management
and we're doing a lousy job we have a
lot of new therapeutic laser
technologies and stuff they're coming
down line but we've got to be able to
predict the disease detect it a lot
earlier so any of you are sons or
daughters of patients with macular
degeneration start having photographs
taken age 50 55 once a year so we can
overlay them and track them and predict
it because with this new therapeutic
laser we're able to reduce the risk of
progression by about 85% so we've got
ways now that we can start applying
earlier and we don't have to resort to
injections in the eye but but we've got
develop better assessment and then I'm
asking you to help and I'm and finally I
I would like to get involved
I think the projects that I've been
hearing I've been phenomenal and I'd
like to sort of give you my slant
sometimes on things if you want to call
me and ask me about a questions off
answer however I can or want to get you
interested in some of the projects that
[Applause]
I was watching these hamsters that would
fit would hybrid a stuff I said why
can't I get it a rat - hi Bernie so I
got I got a physician locally in Phoenix
who sort of said okay Steve we'll try
this and so we put him in my mom's
refrigerator and we would try to measure
their o2 consumption and co2 production
everything finally my mother said Steve
I got to buy you another
yeah okay